- [Narrator] In her first two years
at the Federal Trade Commission,
Chair Lina Khan has already taken on
the biggest tech titans in the world.
- Her beef is with the biggest company.
- [Narrator] And she's
lost big to some of them.
- I'm certainly not somebody who thinks
that success is marked by a
hundred percent court record.
- [Narrator] That strategy
has made her a lightning rod
for controversy and criticism.
- This raises the question, Chair Khan,
are you losing on purpose?
- [Narrator] So what drives her to take on
the toughest fights, and what
happens if she doesn't win?
- Antitrust lawyers say
that this is as aggressive
as they've seen the FTC
in a very long time.
- Over the last century,
we've seen time and time again
that when we have robust
antitrust enforcement
and robust competition,
that really sets us up best
to have the strongest,
most thriving economy.
- [Narrator] In 2021, the year
Khan was sworn in as Chair,
the FTC issued 42 letters
of investigation over M&A,
that's almost twice the amount in 2020,
and the highest in more than a decade.
- When the FTC does investigations,
they type their own
resources, and they tie a deal
in knots for as long as a year.
- [Narrator] And investigating
more deals can slow down
the merger market overall.
- More important is the chilling effect
that they're having on
M&A activity in general.
- [Narrator] Stoller is a friend
and former coworker of Khan.
- They're trying to address activities
that are central to coercive behavior
in the economy right now by
challenging vertical mergers
by big companies, dominant
infrastructure players.
- [Narrator] And it's not just the number
of mergers the FTC investigates.
It's also the type of company
the agency is scrutinizing.
- We are also entirely
outgunned, especially when we are
up against some of the most
formidable and wealthiest
and most powerful companies in America.
- [Narrator] But that hasn't stopped Khan
from taking on companies
like Meta or Microsoft.
- Lina's supporters do think
that she's bringing the
cases that the government
was too chicken in the past to bring.
- [Narrator] But those big shots
haven't necessarily panned out.
In February, the FTC lost
its case to block Meta
from acquiring virtual
reality company Within.
And in early July, a federal
judge sided with Microsoft
after the agency sued to block its merger
with gaming company, Activision.
The FTC appealed and the court rejected
the agency's request to block
the deal in the meantime.
In a statement, Meta said
that the deal would bring
pro-competitive benefits
to the ecosystem.
Microsoft declined to comment.
Despite the losses, Khan
has said it's important
to take those cases to court.
- As public enforcers, we
have a special obligation
to be bringing the hard cases
because if you don't try,
the message that sends
out to the world is that
the enforcers don't think
there's a problem in the market.
- [Narrator] Still, there's
a risk in losing too much.
- It creates bad precedent for you,
and perhaps even Wall Street
and the companies start to tune you out
and think it's worth fighting
you 'cause you're not winning.
Lawyers I've spoken to, they say,
maybe the FTC should take a step back
and think more deeply
about the kinds of deals
that they wanna bring
that will make the points
that Lina's trying to make
- [Narrator] In a
statement, the agency said
that in the last year and a half,
the FTC has had 20 wins
including several mergers
that were abandoned
following FTC scrutiny.
The cases that Khan's FTC has brought
are not always straightforward.
Microsoft and Activision
aren't direct competitors
so the agency needed the court
to buy into its prediction
that the merger could hurt
competition in the future.
The courts have had mixed
responses to that legal theory.
- Lina says that over
the last 30 odd years
that the law came to put too much focus
on what's called the
consumer welfare standard,
which is measuring harm from
deals or from practices,
measuring that in consumer
prices or supply output.
Lina disavows this
consumer welfare standard
is really the purpose
of the antitrust laws.
- What Lina Khan is doing
is to put competition
at the center of antitrust policy again.
And to say, actually it's about this law
is about whether you can let people
into the market or not to compete.
- [Narrator] This approach
is part of what got Khan
to the FTC.
The youngest FTC chair in history,
she'd already made a name for herself
by the time she was appointed.
After graduating from college,
khan worked at a think tech
where she looked at
corporate consolidation.
- It became clear pretty quickly
that there had been a pretty steady trend
of consolidation across the board.
- [Narrator] And in 2017, she
published an article titled
"Amazon's Antitrust Paradox"
when she was still in law school.
- That paper reimagines the
thrust of the antitrust laws.
She wants to think about
antitrust enforcement
and competitive harm
in a much broader way.
- She essentially said,
the way that we do business
in America is, essentially,
should be illegal.
- Amazon declined to comment.
That paper made her an
antitrust celebrity.
- She's a symbol of a new approach
to addressing monopoly power.
- She has come to prominence
at a certain moment
when technology plays a
huge, huge role in our lives,
and that's not gonna change in the future,
it's only gonna get bigger.
- [Narrator] When President
Biden came into office,
he made antitrust a
big part of his agenda.
- I'm a capitalist, but capitalism
without competition is not capitalism.
(audience applaud)
Capitalism without
competition is exploitation.
- When he made her Chair, it
was an indication of policy.
And that was a surprise to me
and I think it was a
surprise to a lot of people.
President Biden thinks
we have a monopoly crisis
and that our monopoly crisis is a serious
and core political economy issue
that he wants to address
as part of his presidency.
- [Narrator] But Khan's
appointment was met with calls
for her to recuse herself
from cases involving companies
she'd criticized in the past.
- Facebook is seeking the
recusal of FTC Chair Lina Kahn.
- I have to tell you that
Amazon's right when they say
that they're entitled to
impartial commissioners.
- It's not a surprise that companies
are gonna throw everything that they have
at the wall to see what sticks.
- [Narrator] She didn't recuse herself
from the Meta/Within case
despite an ethics
officer's recommendation,
prompting blowback.
- There was no violation
under the ethics laws
because I have not a
penny in financial stock.
- [Narrator] Khan is under investigation
by three Republican-led house committees
for her leadership at the FTC.
The agency declined to comment,
but criticism has come
from within the agency too.
Republican Commissioner
Christine Wilson resigned
in early 2023, accusing
Khan of an abuse of power.
The Commission, which
is usually bipartisan,
is now solely democratic.
In a February statement,
Khan and the other commissioners said
that while they often
disagreed with Wilson,
they respect her devotion to her beliefs.
Khan has also faced employee discontent.
- Lina Kahn came in
from the start and said
that the FTC had done
a lot of things wrong.
While that was appealing
to her supporters,
it was probably alienating
to some of her staff
and perhaps also to other
former commissioners
or other former chairs.
- We are fortunate to have
consummate professionals,
extremely talented staff at the FTC.
Of course, we work hard to make sure
that the FTC remains
a great place to work.
- [Narrator] But despite
criticism and skepticism
around her strategy, Khan
says she isn't going anywhere.
- My term goes until, through 2024,
and I fully intend to continue serving.
- [Narrator] Including drafting
aggressive new guidelines
with the justice department
on how the agency will
investigate new mergers.
- It doesn't seem like the FTC has a lot
of time to change its strategy.
So Lina Kahn has a relatively short window
to accomplish as much as she can.
(bright music)